with that I'm going to introduce dr.
savage dr. Sam Savage is an adjunct
prevents professor and civil and
environmental engineering at Stanford
University and executive director of
probability management a non-profit
devoted to making uncertainty actionable
dr. Savage is also the author of the
flaw of averages why we underestimate
risk in the face of uncertainty and is
the inventor of the stochastic
information packet si P a standardized
data array for conveying uncertainty and
so he's very qualified to talk to us
today about how to manage risk in big
projects and he'll also be teaching with
us in the winter you saw some of those
slides at the beginning as Cee 242 are a
course on project risk analysis this is
a graduate seminar but we are accepting
people from outside Stanford so if you
are an online learner who might be
interested in joining that class you can
enroll just go to SCPD scpd's website
okay with that I'm going to turn over
the presentation to Sam and you'll take
it away all right thanks
I know that we have people with probably
very broad background in in their
education and I like to start by
leveling the playing field by by
starting out with something that
everybody understands these are the
differential equations of motion of a
bicycle the point of this slide is to
show that you do not learn to ride a
bicycle
through the seat of your intellect but
through the seat of your pants and I
have a name for this I call it limbic
analytics the limbic system is that part
of the brain that connects the reptilian
brain to the rest of the stuff between
your ears and computers have allowed us
to learn formerly difficult stuff with
our limbic systems it's really very
exciting so I refer to limbic analytics
as connecting the CTL like the seat of
the pants
in my book on the flaw of averages
there's a cartoon of this by the cartoon
is just an sitter so here's someone
connecting the seat of their intellect
and seat of their pants
and so the philosophy of the course and
by the way new technology has really
enabled this approach in analytics and I
want to start out now with the notion of
the flaw of averages so
the averages explains basically why
everything come on why so many projects
are behind schedule
beyond budget and below projection and
we're just going to start out with with
the behind schedule part so suppose the
project involves creating a new website
and it consists of ten pages we've got
the shopping cart page and a legal page
and the credit card page whatever
naturally we're uncertain about how long
each page will take to complete but they
are being created in parallel by 10
separate teams so this is the best of
all possible projects team one does page
one team two does page two when we get
all 10 pages done we can launch the
website but of course we're uncertain
about how long each team will take so on
average they take 6 weeks but ooh you
know that could happen or that could
happen if that could happen but on
average they're 6 weeks so here's here's
where the flaw bad would just comes in
the boss comes in and says hey when's
the website can be up and you say I
don't know boss because I don't know how
paid long page 1 will take a page 2 or
page 3 and then the boss says correct me
if I'm wrong uh give me a number now
give me a number is actually the fork in
the road to hell because after you've
done that you really can't do any more
analysis if you give them a number but
you say to the boss I can't give you a
number but I can give you an average
because on average each of these is 6
weeks so on average this project will be
done in six weeks and the boss says well
if I can give you as an average okay
you've told me 6 weeks so that's what
we're thinking about now what to ask you
question you don't have to answer it on
a pole because we've already done this
poll just think for a second what is the
chance that this project will actually
be done in six weeks 100% 50% one and
four one and ten one hundred one
thousand one in ten thousand don't you
think for just a bit on that last year
we did a poll on this so I know the
answers I know what you think the
answers are okay here goes most people
think Oh 50-50 chance we'll be done in
six weeks
the
the answer is one in a thousand and it's
not enough to just understand that but
you gotta be able to explain it to your
boss
or say a ten year old okay so let me
explain why it's one in a thousand
imagine that each of these ten pages the
duration of each of the ten pages is
either over six weeks or under six weeks
determined by a coin toss well the only
way you can go live in six weeks is if
all Kennedys come in at six weeks or
under and that's like flipping panda
heads in a row which is actually one
thousand one chance in 1,024 so that's
why the answer here is about one in a
thousand now I think it's important to
point out that there have been some
technological breakthroughs
that have allowed enabled a new
discipline that I call probability
management and probability management
makes uncertainty actionable by storing
it as auditable data as an example let's
let's do dice here I'm gonna start out
with dice now we're gonna go back to
that scheduling example which is kind of
like the like the granddaddy of all the
big flaw of abacus problems so here I've
got
data representing 10,000 die rolls for
each of three dice if you've heard of
Monte Carlo simulation then these data
arrays are just the output of a Monte
Carlo simulation but here's the cool
thing there's been a breakthrough in
Excel where there's a function called
the data table which has recently become
much more powerful and so by looking at
these dice by the way see there's trial
one is a four six and five trial two is
a 3 a 2 & a 6 trial like 8775 well for
this one I don't know sorry one of them
in there is three ones and I forget
which one but it's auditable data is the
point there we go see I haven't
memorized all 10,000 trials I knew it
was one of those okay but that's amazing
so that means that that this this whole
simulation approaches auditable but
watch this I can say what happens if I
roll that first die 10,000 times get it
your stopwatch on your mark get set go
okay that was $10,000 what happens if I
add two dice together so I'll add the
first die to the second die and now what
I am doing is I'm doing arithmetic with
uncertainty now when you add two dice
the smallest number you can get is a to
the biggest number you can get is a 12
you get those with equal likelihood see
this histogram we're looking at says oh
yeah all the dice come up all the sides
come up equally likely but if I add two
of them together whoa and that was
10,000 Montecarlo trials in native Excel
well then I see they're more 7th than
anything else because they're more ways
to get a 7 now in the discipline
probability management where we store
uncertainties as a race of data these
things have names these are rays I
decided to call them well you're on I
already knew that you know the audience
out there has got bit and bite you know
permanently tattooed into your brain
somewhere so I knew I needed synth and
slurp just to fit into the receptors you
already had a sip stands for stochastic
information packet that's one of these
columns and slurp is is tortured but
it's stochastic library unit with
relationships preserved we may or may
not get to that during this lecture but
it's very important when you have
multiple uncertainties to preserve any
interrelationship between them so now
let's go back to the scheduling problem
first thing to say is gee how do you
define the flaw of averages
well the flaw of averages states that
plans based on average assumptions are
wrong on average so for example oh yeah
most people think this will be done in
six weeks and fifty 50/50 chance right
no there's one chance in a thousand
that's not close enough even for
government work um so so here's one
example of the flaw of averages consider
the statistician who drowned in the
river that's on average three feet deep
again this is another cartoon by Jeff
dancer bird was illustrated the book
here's a more
sobering example consider a drunk
wandering back and forth on a busy
highway
his average position is the centerline
well that means that at his average
position the drunk is alive yeah but on
average he's dead
not close enough even for government
work now this this was discovered as a
mathematical principle known as Jensen's
inequality and just one of the other
points here in the saw Babbage's book
one of the big problems here in
statistics is that most people that a
statistics course I've got what I call
post-traumatic statistics disorder or
PTSD and so it's important not to use
too much statistical jargon so in the
back of the book I have a glossary well
first of all I have a term for these
words that bring on PTSD I call them red
words so let me just show you the red
word the green word green means it's
okay you can say it the flaw of averages
you can say this law of averages the red
word equivalent that you heard in your
math course or statistics course is
Jensen's inequality and that's the
formal definition of a red word is
something that could not be uttered in a
singles bar for example but anyway
there's that there is a glossary in the
back of a book of these red words and
green words and you don't really need to
zoom in there but you know when you get
there they're written in dracula font
the pub this was the publishers idea i
love it so i go back now to the drunk in
the road mathematicians have known about
this for over a century as Jensen's
inequality I call it the flaw of
averages this is a public relations
issue here and as a public relations
issue
I developed an audio logo for the flaw
of averages so well here you recognize
this audio logo you should go over here
this
[Music]
that's of course you know a big chip
maker you should recognize their audio
logo
here's the flaw of averages audio logo
[Music]
so let's go back now to this project
model and I'm going to show you now how
we actually can make actionable
decisions based on uncertainty we to
start out with we have a sip library
that that is to say this was not your
first rodeo
you've been building web pages for a
while you know how long it takes to
build web pages
yeah it's uncertain we can model that
uncertainty with a sip library so here
we have a thousand possible scenarios
and
so when I'm scrolling through I'm
looking through each of a thousand
possibilities oh you wanted 10,000 we
could you're ten thousand you want a
million we could do a million that would
be excels limit but you want to do it in
Python or R or something else you could
do a hundred million if you needed you
thousand is probably enough so this is a
business problem however unfortunately
someone has promised this job in seven
weeks and if you missed seven weeks then
there's $100,000 per week late penalty
lucky they didn't promise six weeks so
let's take a look at this
if I plug in the averages that I'm done
in six weeks with no penalty no that
can't happen like like this scenario one
68,000 in penalty seven point seven
here's scenario two I don't want the
output given the average input I want
the average of these overall thousand
trials that's what the flaw of averages
distinguishes between and this again is
just a native excel file you could you
can download this off the probability
management dot org website and share it
with 1.2 billion of your closest friends
it's just made of Excel I didn't show
you this before but we're using the data
table out here to run a thousand trials
you know with every keystroke face to
face and so now let's take a look at
what the average results are average
overall thousand trials so the outcome
of the average inputs is six weeks and
no penalty but on average it's seven
point eight weeks and eighty six
thousand eight hundred thirty three
dollars difference between these two is
the flaw of averages now how would we
use this in to make better decisions
well the first thing is you go crawling
back to the counterparty on your hands
and knees and make oh please please
please would you lower our penalty to
fifty thousand because notice you're
getting nailed here on average it's like
almost eighty seven thousand so let's
lower the penalty to fifty sounds right
and they say oh we be happy to do that
but then we're going to demand that you
finished in six weeks
oh no now our penalty is ninety two
thousand bucks oh my god so you say wait
a second working with you how about if
we would you give us eight weeks to
finish and they say sure we're happy to
do that
if you finish if if you are willing to
accept $150,000 penalty and you say so
old
that's 23,000 on average okay so really
what's important here is that the
discipline of probability management is
going to let us determine number one the
true average of things happening and
number two of the chance of things
happening so let me show you a couple of
other examples of the flaw of averages
just so you understand that this is not
an isolated phenomenon but is actually
ubiquitous so I don't know if anyone has
ever heard of the potential of say
sea-level rise or just flooding in
general here's an example where we have
a little municipality they have a creek
that floods there are dikes along the
side of the creek the average flood
crest by the way is 2.4 meters and and
the height of the dikes
is 2.5 meters so given the average flood
there's no damage at all here's a little
table of damage down here right so at
one point eight two meters the nursery
school floods it's a million bucks then
the fire house at five million then the
railroad station of ten million the
airport at 20 million fine to the
hospital up here at five meters so let's
remember it's
to get a sip library the sip is this
array of potential floods and this is
why we have a National Weather Service
you know to provide these things because
let's remember a bunch of stuff that
happened like there are actually a
thousand floods in here that could
happen oh yeah it could you know could
go way down Oh or that could happen or
that could happen or that could have ups
so what's happening is on that trial we
had 30 million in damage but of course
given the average flood there's no
damage but what is you averaged over all
possible floods then the damage they're
going to be five and a half million
dollars so this is an absolutely
ubiquitous problem now the the course is
going to use my book and I do not want
to induce PTSD in people so it really
turns out there are these fives
I call them mind dolls okay a mind Elise
for the mind what a handle is for the
hand a hand to let you grasp something
like you know like a hammer a mind to
let you grasp one of these these
slippery concepts so the Mindil for the
flaw of averages is the drunk in the
road or the statistician in the river
but basically one section the book is
devoted to the models and it's not even
a big section but they're all all five
mind those are only the only five
concepts they're all basically on one
page in the book for those of you who
have the book by the way it's on page 47
there are five things you really have to
understand to improve your risk
intelligence risk intelligence is an
important concept
that's what limbic analytics does is
improve your risk intelligence you have
to go off and look at things like the
differential equations of motion of a
bicycle you can just know this stuff is
wrong so let me give you some other one
other really interesting example of
where this whole probability management
approach is being applied it just it
just means that we are representing
uncertainties as a rays of data don't
just work in Excel works anywhere
there's this open standard called the
SIPP math standard that can be applied
in R in MATLAB in Python in Excel and
one of the interesting places we're
beginning to apply it now it's military
readiness actually so this is a
conceptual model of an air wing on an
aircraft carrier you have so many Strike
Fighters and growlers and these things
and you know these planes are not flying
all the time you know there might be up
about 80% of the time but you know
they're fixing the flat tires they're
emptying the ashtrays
whatever they do to keep the plane is
fine and so you you might have a a
mission requirement you say listen if we
have to fly this mission today
I need 30 strike fighters three growlers
three of these radar planes one of these
and twelve helicopters
what's my chance of being ready
so the
go back to give me a number so give me a
number give me a number is the fork in
the road to hell but the course is gonna
teach you how to deal with that with the
boss and I'm just gonna give you the
bottom line when the boss says give me a
number you say what do you want it to be
I'll tell you the chances very important
so if the boss wants this many aircraft
of these tight you say well your chance
is 61% of carrying that mission off
today if we just have to do it at random
bam we have to fly this thing 61% chance
so other buses well gee what if I what
if I back off the strike fighters and oh
by the way if we look down at the bottom
this sheet were also learning the chance
that any particular type of aircraft was
holding us up and received the strike
fighters in the event we can't fly the
mission there's a 43% chance it was the
strike fighters 35% chance it was the
helicopters what if I back off to say
you know 25 of these and I back off the
helicopters to Ken whoa by doing that
we've increased our chance of being able
to fly the mission to 82% from 61% now
which
to attempt to fly is above my pay grade
but the person who makes that decision
should be informed with chances not with
averages
all right so let me now show you a bit
how we solve these problems from scratch
and oh I'll tell you what because this
course is actually in project management
here's something I just have to show
this is a template that just came
straight out of Excel if you go to excel
and you open template you open new file
and you put in a little search and you
put in like project planning or
something this template pops up and we
simply modified this to take in sit math
so sit back being me it's open standard
for using the data table to do
simulations so I'm going to check this
little box click whoa suddenly this
thing is in simulation mode and you can
do that or that or that or that by the
way one of the things we do in the class
is I have students go down and go ahead
and download these various project
planning templates and then they can add
their own probabilistic stuff into it so
so this is taking this ready-made
template and yeah there's a little work
to do it but not that much work I look
it up to the data table it's that's
definitely one of my favorite models all
right so let's now talk about sort of
applying this and the stuff we're gonna
learn in the course for building models
oh and
before I do that I realize I can do it
after that this is all based on
something in Excel called the data table
function which you find here data
what-if analysis data table now the fact
is there's some free tools out of the
nonprofit's website where you can where
you can demonstrate the tools in a
second and they help you build the data
table so you don't really need to do
this from scratch but let's look at this
model I told you that the flaw baggages
explains why so many projects are behind
schedule
beyond budget and below projection this
is the below bridge projection project
and basically this would be something
like a uh a capital investment project
we have to build a factory or something
to produce things or or I'm going to
make a really simple version where we
just have to order stuff for the
Christmas season but the point is we
have an uncertain demand for a product
so here the cost per unit get order six
months in advance cost per unit thirty
bucks selling price forty bucks
we know that with certainty we're
uncertain about the demand and again we
have to order six months in advance but
everybody agrees the average demand is a
hundred thousand units so we order a
hundred thousand units now the boss
comes in
it says what's profit going to be and
you say I don't know boss because I
don't know what demands gonna be and
then the boss says give me a number and
you say would you settle for an average
profit the bus's if it's all you can
give me that's easy enough we plug in a
thousand for our demand and revenue is
forty times 100,000 it for four million
and cost the goods with 30 times a
hundred thousand that's three million so
the profit is 1 million yeah that's the
profit of the average but is that the
average profit so it doesn't take long
to find out what would happen
the demand was 90,000 well if the demand
is 90,000 you only make $600,000 sure
but what if the demand was 110,000 see
what I'm doing here is I am
experimenting with a model what is
demands little higher what if it's a
little low so if the demand is lower we
went down to 600,000 what's a little
high
oh we're still at a million dollars
we're capped at a million dollars you
can't make more than a million dollars
did you only ordered a hundred thousand
of these widgets whatever they are so
let's go back to a two hundred thousand
we see that the Prime
thousand of Adam and if the demanders on
two thousand the profit is a million but
if profit goes down we make less money
profit goes up we don't make more money
how could something less than a million
and something equal to a million average
out to a million it can't
[Music]
the average isn't a million that's the
best possible case now I'm going to
invoke the sick math modeler tools and
again the website is probability
management org is the nonprofit where
you can grab these um and here's what
I'm going to do in this case there is a
sip library waiting for me to plug in to
this cell I don't know how to do Monte
Carlo simulation to do this alright let
me give you an analogy here I presume
that many of you have heard of
Montecarlo simulation because I've again
it's not my first rodeo and I know when
people who show off these things they've
heard him on a Carlo a technique
developed during the Manhattan Project
where they developed the atomic bomb and
to use Monte Carlo simulation you have
to know a lot about statistics so you
have to have to know how to generate all
these random numbers that go into your
into your model and that's why too
can't all use Montecarlo well that's one
reason the other reason was you had to
buy expensive Montecarlo simulation
software okay
now you don't now Montecarlo will run in
native excel so we got that problem out
of the way but we still have the problem
of well I'm not an expert how would I
know how to generate the random numbers
well let me ask you something
do you use the light bulbs by any chance
I'll bet you do
do you know how to generate the
electricity that goes into the light
bulbs oh I bet you don't and that's a
few of you were working in a power
company right now so how did we work
that out well we had the electrical
engineers generate the power in power
plants and then distribute it over power
lines to the people who needed it and to
do that we had to invent the 60 cycle AC
current standard actually the people
invented it were called Westinghouse and
Tesla and so now that we have that
standard we can distribute we can
distribute electricity than the people
who generate to the people who need it
we can now distribute probability
distributions from the people who know
how to generate them to the people who
need them
I call this distribution distribution so
what I'm going to do is now use the
stick math tools and yet now once I
could generate your own electricity if I
knew what X our statistician but suppose
I'm not I'm just someone who wants to
predict the profit here and I'm gonna go
to an external workbook and I'm gonna
browse to a workbook called demand this
workbook has in it
sip of demand here's that workbook
just opened it for me and where's the
sip oh it's right there it's a plus sign
all thousand trials are demands good
okay um then it's got some metadata in
here and it's in this open standard
format that sent me a format which also
could be done in XML or comm separate
values or whatever so now I'm back at my
model the next thing I do is I put my
cursor in that cell and I go to library
input
demand so it now knows I have demand I
click okay I'm gonna overwrite the
number oh wow now I have a little
picture of a distribution in that cell
how about that all it's done is put in
an index statement to that other file
now and so I could look at say trial one
trial two trial three trial nine it's
kind of it
oh yeah trial nine is pretty nasty isn't
it demand was sixty-six thousand eight
hundred sixty-two yeah you lost three
hundred twenty-five thousand on that
trial you go back and set it to the
average so given the average in forex
we're making a million bucks you might
want to know what the real averages by
the way so I put the cursor in that cell
I click on define outputs I give the
name profit
oh and let me just show you something
here before I do that when I initialized
the model it created a separate sheet
where the data table is going to be
established remember at every stage I
have a model that can be shared with 1.2
billion people the tools are like sawing
hammer working on wood if you build a
doghouse out of wood you don't need a
sawn hammer the dog doesn't need a saw
in hammer
he used the doghouse no you know so
Excel is the wood out of which were
building stuff and I just showed you
this data table
she's there's nothing on it yet but as
soon as I say define outputs and I'm
gonna give it a name profit I click OK
and a thousand trials later oh my
goodness there are there's a sip of a
thousand profits oh yeah well duh the
biggest up you can get is a million cuz
you only ordered one hundred thousand
one hundred thousand widgets ok now
first question you might ask is what is
the average profit well this this data
table over here is actually named this
range if I look at that range of out
quarts the range is called profits
here's a range name if you know what
range names are in Excel so I could
simply go to the model and I could say
okay what's the average profit and I
could type in equals average of profit
and it says
Oh 600,000 roughly the profit of the
average was a million the average profit
is six hundred not close enough even for
folk music alright now the real question
is what are the chances right so how do
you know you're doing probability
management you're able to answer
questions of the form what are the
chances of something for example the
boss might say well what's the chance of
making eight hundred thousand and how do
we do that well like let's see eight
hundred thousand I want the chance that
I'm greater than that I go over here
I click on the chance of whatever button
there's my output the chance that the
thing is greater than 800,000 is 58% now
of course I'm an expert so I knew that I
could do that in my head but you know
you probably would have need to do a a
simulation to find out the chance that
it's greater by the way what's the
chance that it's greater than 900,000
54% now I want to get to more of the
stuff with the tools I had a nice
question saying interview that I want to
get to you but let's just do one other
kind of decision-making exercise here I
hope you did
tell the boss to expect a million
dollars which you would have done if you
plugged in the average demand and then
read off the process but you probably
did too bad nobody asked this why is it
a hundred thousand but why is it only a
million why are we capped at a million
right so so in other words when if I go
up to a a higher let's go to let's go to
a case where I have oh well this is good
enough
ma-mutt my actual demands 141,000 but I
only have sales allowed a thousand
because all I can sell is what I ordered
so if the actual is greater than the
ordered I only get to sell the ordered
otherwise the actual this is an if
statement in Excel it means if it's not
that complicated so I didn't get to sell
those extra ones so maybe I should have
ordered more like what if I ordered
120,000 would that be better
let's try uh-oh
if you wonder 120,000 your and its
profit is below 300,000 that's a
disaster what if I ordered less let's
say order 80,000 oh my profits more I
went up to 260 almost six six hundred
eighty thousand and by the way this is
where limbic analytics comes in here
control Z control Y control z back to
ordering on a thousand control wide
ordering eighty thousand when you think
limbic analytics you should think the
scene in Jurassic Park where Jeff
Goldblum is waving the flashlight in
front of the Tyrannosaurus to keep it
from eating the Jeep with the kids in it
alright motion you've got to do things
interactively to get the boss's
attention okay let's see if in the time
remaining I can I can quickly answer
what I thought was a very good question
here from someone on
[Music]
how to model
slow and when you might run out of money
so a very common thing in a project is
mmm-hmm that you you have to start off
by funding a project we'd say a million
bucks and then eventually you start
bringing in cash
but you don't get it right away mmm
so let's say that I'll cash out in this
project our cash out is why do I give a
million in funding so that's our cap but
we have to put in like 250,000 in first
month and 250,000 second months then we
work our way down hundred thousand
hundreds out by the way it keeps not
hurt
600,000 got no just to keep the thing
operating but then the cash starts
coming in no cash first month no cash
second month but you know then you get
that's gonna be fifty thousand then
100,000 100,000 admit it starts in month
a it starts ramping up to two hundred
thousand and if you look at that here's
your cash position over time maybes
model or it exists I should point
something out what would happen if we
required like like 600,000 here
well then you can see we get down very
close
we don't get to 0 what if I needed
700,000 or 800,000 oh well once you get
to zero you stay at CR when you run out
of money you're dead okay so there's the
model basically out of the box violating
this law of averages so now let me show
you how we would basically use the tools
to model this and what I'm going to use
here will be learning how to use the
tools in the course so I'm not expecting
you but by the way there there are
online tutorials and things so I hope
that you'll download the free tools but
it does take a little training to do
this stuff because now I'm not just
using sip libraries I'm actually
learning electrical engineering you know
how to how to model the uncertainty and
one very simple way to model in certain
situations is with something called a
triangular distribution and the
triangular distribution is is pretty
brain-dead let me say but but I'm going
to use it to get us started so so my
first step here is I have estimates for
each of these months this is for my cash
in I have a minimum of most likely and a
max and I'm going to turn those into
uncertainties in the model so now I'm
going to initialize the model I'm going
to say I mean generate mode I know what
I'm doing I'm gonna generate my own
electricity I click OK and then I'm
gonna go to the cash in section
and I'm going to go to generate input
and I'm going to say this is going to be
a triangular distribution
and I have the minimum I don't have it
looks like Lee and I have the maximum
now it also needs me to put in one of
Xillia set of data here to put in some
some additional random numbers that that
drive the trinary distribution ah but
now now the cash in column has got
uncertainties in de in it and
scroll through them here try one trial
to trial free trial for trial five trial
600 went bankrupt in try in month five
right and so let me put that one away I
bet cuz I got one in the oven already to
come out here naturally alright I mean
let me show you what what you get to
eventually so here we have a model in
which it's pure Excel so I don't have to
use the tools to scroll through the
trials let me point that out there's
this number on the pm table sheet which
is called km index and so I can control
it from here there's trial one trial to
trial three four five Oh went bankrupt
in month four I have here I have here
sell this column sells tracks the month
in which I went bust if I don't go bust
it all up puts a hundred in there and up
here I have the minimum of those so oh
yeah I went bust in month four if I go
back to trial one one hundred business
doesn't mean I went busting in trial an
otherwise I didn't go bust at all and so
looking for the average of when you went
bust isn't even a sensible thing could
you might never go bust right the
company might last forever
you can't average like infinity in with
a bunch of oh I can ask the chance
what's the chance I'd go bust in in four
months
fourteen percent how about five months
six months how about 12 months 13 months
well 13 months is the highest I mean
this means you didn't go bust but that
means there's a 43% chance you will go
bust within the first year which is
important and then you could ask them
questions like well ooh what if we went
for more funding how about 1.2 million
that didn't help that much okay
how about 2 million oh oh no wait a
minute uh hold on hold on hold on hold
on me undo I look at the wrong cell 43
percent chance of going bust with a
million okay 1.1 million that drops to
6% oh that might be something you'd like
to know if you're funding this project
right 1.2 percent zero chance so sorry I
messed that up again but but you can see
now would undo and redo look at this
chance we'll do a little Olympic
analytics chance of going bust with a
million dollars of the funding 43% and
then let's see control why I'll let 1.1
million we're down to 6 percent
1.2 million we're at zero okay so
there's an example of the kind of stuff
that most people aren't even doing
they're not talking about chances
they're plugging in averages they're
getting horrible answers and that's
where they
stop so and this is what I would like to
stop and take a few questions thank you
so much thank you so much Sam so we just
have we have only a couple minutes so I
think there's one kind of trying to to
sort of organize all the questions into
one central question so I love this idea
of limbic analytics and we know even
that from studies that most
statisticians don't think accurately
about statistics outside of when they're
doing the actual statistical work so a
couple questions have come in about how
do you deal how have you seen changes in
companies beyond the kind of programs
that you're doing to deal with this
problem so someone mentioned agile
project development where you're dealing
with instead of a giving a single number
you're giving a range what what kinds of
developments cultural developments have
you seen in the companies to move
towards a better understanding of
probability and risk yes
so the agile development is is just
beautiful it is really in the bull's eye
of solving these problems if you can't
you're probably properly with
uncertainty so just make your decisions
more often as things change right
you actually can prove using thus law of
averages that agile development gives
you greater optionality which is one of
the things that this law of averages
addresses so that agile development is
definitely helping to solve these
problems with uncertainty I think
interestingly though
- maturely dealing with uncertainty you
will find some industries like finance
so in finance people look at risk return
curves and they have since the 1960's
with regularity you
in theory people are looking at that
uncertainly explicitly but frankly there
is a huge amount of low-hanging fruit
today to go out and adopt these methods
today and for example when you look at
how people do risk regulation I think
this is worth sharing I think this is
this is a very very important it when
people regulate risk here's an important
definition of risk likelihood a failure
times
points of failure so the likelihood of
failure
suppose that so the failure is you know
there's an accident someone gets and if
it happens there's one chance someone
gets killed right okay but the
likelihood so llf so this is 10% 10%
chance and the consequence is one
fatality right and so this definition of
risk says the risk here is that times
that or 0.1 fatalities and by the way
this is used in regulation all right
well let me ask you this what if there
was a 0.01 percent that's a 1% chance
okay let's see um 100 of 10 fatalities
well wait a minute that's still point
one well what if there was a point zero
one percent chance I got to add more
decimal so we can even see it
chance of hundred fatalities or a
thousand fatalities it was 1,000 there
we go it's still point one so so this
measured risk does not distinguish
between killing one person and killing a
thousand people it is in common use in
regulation so there's a huge amount of
low-hanging fruit for people to go out
and learn about this stuff still in
their organizations and change those
organizations from within but great
question and agile development is a step
in the right direction that's fantastic
and so in a big piece of it of course is
is having these exceptions being able to
play with the model in front of someone
to show demonstrate of as the numbers
change how in real-time that's changing
the risk risk intelligence now is being
monitored and and some people have it
and some don't
gamblers have it because they've been
involved in limbic analytics they've
left their butts on the line in the
casino and they're quite good at this
well we're pretty much out of time I
guess I want to remind everyone that
Professor Savage will be teaching this
in more depth I posted the link to the
course in the chat box if you're
interested professor savage also has
some some edited videos on a lot of
these topics on his website so you can
go there as well for tutorials and
refresh yourself or to inform your
company about these important topics so
I want to thank professor savage again
today I want to thank all of you for
being here today and we really
appreciate your time and we hope you
enjoyed it thank you thank you
you